Our country has gone backwards in its decision to impose
Visa to Mexicans.
A communiqué from the Foreign Ministry
says it will not be demanded
this visa
for those who want to visit our country
with respect to the Pacific alliance agreements,
something that of course
has not been taken into account by the Mexican government.
But it is important to say that even when
it can be believed that the Peruvian government
has given in
or that it should
respond more to Mexico,
when Mexico
does impose a notice as of April 20
to ours,
it must be said that the decision seems to be well thought out.
and smart,
because they are the tourism unions
those who have called for the elimination of this requirement,
more than 70,000 Mexicans arrive,
76,300 have visited our country in 2,023.
More Mexicans have arrived in Peru than France,
Canada and the United Kingdom.
So we've thought a lot more with our heads,
we have reflected and well,
let's open Peru's doors to more Mexicans